gucken wir mal rein wie viel freiheit
hier drin steckte in dem neuen corona
plan der bundesregierung das ist vom
gestrigen abend da ist nur noch in
einzelnen formulierungen dran geschraubt
worden das wird relativ schnell
beschlossen werden wahrscheinlich in
diesem corona gipfel man ist sich einig
dass es nicht nur schnelle freiheit gibt
sondern eine langsame schnecken freiheit
in drei schritten schauen wir mal rein
hier in das papier das dann eben ab 14
uhr nochmal final beraten und dran
geschraubt wird mit dem
gesundheitsminister und dem
ministerpräsidenten das ganze wie gesagt
in drei schritten hier stets dreischritt
der öffnungen in bereichen
überregionaler oder grundsätzlicher
bedeutung man kompliziert formuliert
hier dieser dreischritt und entscheidend
ist dann dieses datum auf das man hin
steuert also das soll so eine art
freedom day werden dieser zwanzigste
märz 2022 aber gucken sie mal auf den
kalender das ist halt einfach noch mehr
als fünf wochen hin leider da sollen
dann alle tief greifenden maßnahmen
endlich weg alle tief greifenden coroner
regeln und da ist noch die große frage
wie definiert das eigentlich der
gesundheitsminister selbst oder was sind
jetzt tiefgreifende maßnahmen die maske
jedenfalls sollen nicht dazu gehören die
sollen dann fallen am 20 märz uns bis
dahin gibt's so ganz vorsichtige öffnung
schritte gucken sie mal der erste ist
nämlich echt verdammt vorsichtig private
zusammenkünfte für geimpfte und genesene
werden hier geregelt also wusste ich
persönlich gar nicht dass das immer noch
begrenzt ist ehrlich gesagt den privaten
das wird also jetzt im ersten schritt
gelockert aber noch nicht für ungeimpfte
sobald ungeimpfte dabei sind gelten
wieder die ganz engen kontakt
beschränkung auch im privaten und dann
gibt's im zweiten schritt der gibt schon
mal ein bisschen mehr her hier am
vierten märz 2022 eröffnet dem ich dann
die gastronomie für geimpfte und
genesene und alle mit einem
tagesaktuellen test also dass dann
endlich schluss mit 2g und 3g plus in
der gastronomie zumindest für clubs gilt
das weiter fort aber eben nicht für die
gastronomie und dann das was sie gerade
schon gesagt hab dann steuern wir auf
diesen zwanzigster märz 2022 hin also da
sollen dann diese
tiefgreifenderen hier stets tief
greifenden schutzmaßnahmen die sollen
dann enden und da hoffen wir dass das
wirklich tief greifend auch formuliert
wird also das dann wirklich endgültig
schluss ist mit den chor ohne regeln 1
habe ich schon gesagt die masten pflicht
die wird weiter fort gelten bis ins dorf
übrigens gibt es in diesem corona gipfel
noch um den genesenen status da hat die
union da haben die cdu csu
ministerpräsidenten gestern später am
abend noch mal ein bisschen dran
geschraubt da geht sie mich vor allen
dingen darum wer bestimmt das jetzt wie
lange der genesenen status gilt karl
lauterbach hat hierbei bild gesagt ich
bin's ich bin's karl lauterbach ich
möchte dass regeln und die
unions-ministerpräsidenten sagen die
nähe also das machst du mal schön nicht
im alleingang das macht nicht der wiler
vom rk ii das machst du aber auch nicht
da wollen wir mitreden und der soll
wieder ein halbes jahr gelten also da
gibt es heute noch zoff ansonsten dieser
dreischritt bei den chor ohne regeln bei
den öffnungen der scheint relativ klar
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt